it is also craft week and we have a
crochet designer who's been crocheting
since the age of 13
and a business owner since the age of 15
and she's joining us from philadelphia
hey cbs 3 by the way please welcome
amani
[Applause]
okay i have to tell you i am freaking
out about your business model it is the
coolest thing i've ever seen
take a look at this you created the
world's first yarn vending machine
yes i did i did i mean and now
you have multiple of them in
philadelphia
your business is expanding cardi b
has worn one of your designs armani
are you up for a challenge to make
something throughout the show and maybe
create a little piece by the time we're
done yes drew please challenge me
if anything please challenge me okay
imani we're
gonna do that and we're gonna check in
with you throughout the whole show and
keep chatting
all right let's that's fine okay thanks
imani so
much thank you thank you thank you and i
wanted to check in with imani
how's it going it's going fine drew
almost done oh my gosh it's beautiful
and that's my favorite color
yeah they told me you love yellow it's
true it's our signature color of the
show what are you making
a bikini oh no way yeah
oh my god all right i'm gonna go on a
diet right now
um imani you're so amazing i'm gonna
check back in with you and i wanna know
uh how and why you started your business
i'll be right back with you
probably in the news break okay thank
you imani you're so beautiful
let's check in with our intrepid crochet
designer
imani who's been crocheting something
special for us throughout the show
imani how's it going it's going it's
going
we're almost done okay i'm so excited
i'm going to check
back in with you in the next segment and
uh see you again
hey lonnie how's it going i'm checking
in with you we're almost
out of time we're all done here's the
bottom
and here's the top oh amani you are so
amazing and if you want to go to our
website we're going to feature imani's
website because you starting a business
at 15
you have so much to teach people thank
you so much for being on the show today
and to all
of our veteran friends and family today
honored honored to spend this time with
you
please take this with you for the rest
of this most important veterans day
we'll see you soon cheers
[Music]